who should be having a car
and who should be just ubering around
uber everywhere uber everywhere
let's get into who should have a car now
who should have a car
if you're going long distances if you
have a long commute if you're in the car
for a half hour hour you're driving
places
you get a long commute that will add up
in an uber or lift that's probably not
for you
if you're taking multiple daily trips
you're going to the store and then
you're going for lunch and then you've
got to go get some milk
then you got to pick up your kids if
you're making multiple daily trips that
can get
really really annoying in a car or uber
next thing is if there's limited public
transportation around you maybe you're
in a rural area
you don't have subways or buses or
trains anywhere near you maybe you need
to have a car
what else if you want to have pride if
you want to kind of do your thing and
you want to have a sense of ownership
and stability and you want to have
status status is a big thing
then maybe you need to have a car i get
it last but not least
family if you got a family with kids and
pets and pile them in the car
and you're doing your thing then you
probably want to take the whole family
in an uber and a lift i get it
however here's the catch maybe you only
need one
car for the whole family i don't know
what are your thoughts on that we just
established at the very beginning here
that the average
household has 1.88 cars just under two
cars
but i know a lot of people are just
saying you know what screw it i'm just
doing one car these days
for the family we'll save that money and
we'll uber elsewhere that's an option
moving right along who should uber now
if you're living a short distance from
where you're going if you live close to
the office maybe you're only
5-10 minutes from the office you should
definitely consider uber especially
these days if you're working from home
if you're working remote
the car is sitting there 95 of the time
collecting dust you don't have a long
drive
you maybe need to think about ubering
everywhere you go
if you're only taking a few daily trips
no big deal if you're at an office all
day
if you have access to public
transportation if you can easily just
jump in a subway
or a train or a bus no big deal you can
maybe just uber and not have a car
obviously if you're single it's just you
you're doing your thing you don't got
kids you don't got a family
it's probably easy to uber i've done
that it works for me will it work for
you last but not least
drinking obviously if you're drinking
you want to avoid a dui i don't care if
you have a car
or not have a car don't be caught
drinking and driving avoid that dui
definitely use an uber okay so you've
seen the numbers you've seen the stats
you've seen the figures the only
question is this
what works best for you only you can
answer that